Hello
, it's a new year, so it's raining at the festival in winter, but
it's snowing this week.
That's fine.
This is my office.
I'm studying words here.  There was an eyeper,
and my current video is made here.
Equipment day like
this Then why would you like to talk about the heat about this extinction?
Econo Mae
My good boy's channel day
Hayashi  d 3 I'm from South Africa called ethics, but I live in Singapore, but
I'm in the neighborhood with expansion and that video.
I'll put it in the north, but
most of it was in English, but I talked to her about some Japanese and Korea in the middle
, but she's already a
bed reckless, so the Hanya issue is trying various words from Tagalog.
I'm enthusiastic about peeping, so in order to study a language, the attitude of the person who studies it
is extremely important.  But if,
for example, the various exams, the drills, or the
like, I want to study the feats hard,
at least in my case, that enthusiasm is
getting colder.
Suppose that the enthusiasm is originally a
certain amount of screw, and
the so-
called activity of studying, or the village where there is no activity.
It's good, it's better to use it, so it's boring when studying.
No matter how much anyone does, it doesn't make much progress.
It's not skiing
content It's interesting for
me and it's better to study around that kind of thing.
You said that you were on a newlyweds trip,
right?
When I can understand the words to some
extent, I can say something to some extent Yellow. Even if I could say that
it was fun when I got that condition, it would
be 3 months, and after that,
I could speak really fluently.  You have to last for a long
time just to be long, but it's not good if you don't
have fun.
Any program is fine, but
it's also music, singing, podcasting, and fun.
If you do that, it's more fun and fun than studying hard to go,
but it's also effective, but if it
works, we  It's emotional, it's
easy to accept the new word, and
it's
not only fun, but it's effective
because it doesn't have a body, and it doesn't end in three months, so at
least think of it as a series.  That's why it should be
, so the so-called three-month-old
podcast breaks through to some extent when it
hits the teeth.
There is no such thing, but the process of studying itself is fun,
so it doesn't matter if it's been May or January.
It's been a year to
bake
English English to improve Level up
Eh,
I'm always using links I'm always using links Links are a fun way to study So now there is a 40% 40% disco
nt, so quick here
Please do so and continue to
do your best in the next video I'd like to talk about your computer
Then everyone it
b 2